if you're watching this video you must
have seen the news a new festival is
coming to brussels in june and we're
happy to see you're interested to learn
more about it in this short tutorial i
will tell you more about the festival of
the new european bauhaus and how you can
apply to join this exciting event
but first things first let me tell you
shortly about the european bajas as well
it's a creative and interdisciplinary
initiative that connects the european
green deal to our living spaces and
experiences and it brings together
science and technology art and culture
to transform our societies along three
values sustainability aesthetics and
inclusion
so let's give life to the european
bauhaus by a festival shall we
a hybrid event will take place from 9 to
the 12th of june and it will feature
live performances exhibitions
participatory activities and a forum for
debate
the main activities will take place
physically in brussels but equally
online with side events across europe
and beyond it will be a moment to
involve everyone to debate and design
the future ways of living together
you can now apply to be part of the
festival the calls are open until
midnight on the 7th of march to
individual artists and cultural actors
public or non-governmental organizations
or any other type of organization
available at regional national european
or international level
you can propose your own activities
projects venues or side events to become
one of the spotlights of our festival
there are four calls available each one
of them corresponding to one of these
proposals so you can apply to either all
of them or one of them but let's
navigate to them quickly so you
understand them better
fest is basically a call for celebration
and cultural program with a range of
performances art pieces participatory
activities and festivities in pop-up
spaces in brussels
so let's say you're a young musician and
a band
or a choir who loves singing but needs a
stage well we're more than happy to
provide you the stage musical
performances such as concerts or live
music will be one of the main features
of the program or maybe you're a painter
or graffiti artist or illustrator well
we offer you the canvas you bring your
talent you have the freedom to either
organize an exhibition or a live
artistic program
and then don't worry you can do that
even if you have a space or not if you
do not we'll simply offer you one just
make sure that you state this in your
application form
the fair
will be mainly a live exhibition in
brussels showcasing projects while
offering opportunities to meet interact
and exchange ideas so you have been
working hard you say on
a bicycle for the last couple of years
well bring it to the festival and not
happily take it for a ride and share my
views or maybe you have a community led
project for sustainable vegetable
production
would love tasting those
so we'll make sure you get the promotion
and visibility you deserve you just
bring your project either with the space
or not once again we'll make sure that
you'll receive corresponding spaces in
brussels as needed collaboration is at
the core of every aspect of our festival
so we aim at getting local communities
engaged in new ways of meeting and
cooperating by connecting inspiring
initiatives with physical spaces across
19 municipalities of brussels
you can propose your space be it museum
cultural space cafe or any other sort of
space to host activities from other
participants your venue will attract
large numbers of visitors and will have
the opportunity to promote your plays
stories and ideas to a wider public
let's call ourselves the pigeons will
help spread the message and make sure
your venue receives the outermost
attention it deserves
lastly you're welcome to propose side
events as well no matter where they are
taking place but just make sure they
overlap at least one day with the main
festival we'll offer you the online
space you need and will promote it as
one of our side events
we are working full throttle to prepare
the event but it would be nothing
without you since the beginning the
european bauhaus has been a
participatory project where we want to
co-create and experiment together
we want to make this festival a first
living experience of the new european
bauhaus with as many and as diverse
activities as possible
so go here and select the call or the
calls
that you're interested in and apply your
application should be submitted by not
later than 7th of march 2022 at midnight
throughout march
will assess your application and in
early april you will be notified of your
results don't worry
last but not least stay tuned for a live
information session
on the 21st of february from 11 in the
morning we'll be organizing a live
information session
with q a's
the event details can be found here
you'll find out more and be able to ask
your questions thank you so much looking
forward for you to be part of our event
[Music]
you